guarda tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo fantastico mirabolante unico
video di rocket league con il pompa vi è
il monster che abbiamo fatto insieme l
ultimo video abbiamo fatto un delle tane
così a tutti quindi vediamo di riuscire
a fare
robben decenti anche oggi speriamo forse
no forse andiamo in diamante 3 comunque
perché altre due tre vittorie di fila
potremmo non è male vada visto
attenzione ragazzi ragazzi mentre più
lucidi codino ragazzi ragazzi no no li
facciamo questo video ripartiamo da
quando è così io mi scoraggio tantissimo
per la parte occhio dopo la tocca tocca
tocca tocca
non ci credo manda loro un angolo ecco
il filmato la mamma come sono arrivato
per sbaglio proprio mamma mia con cosa
stiamo che sta succedendo ita partita
per la sanità andarsene tua aggressiva
non mancarono bravissimo iniziata che
destina al architetture farti male
non ci credo no ragazzi non entrato
niente né di qua né di là pazzesco razzo
sono meritati sto palo dopo una cena
dove l'abbiamo ribilanciato le spinge ok
ok
vai controllata male sufficienza alkalaj
qualche modo aspettando che arrivi ma
chi è sta roba
no ragazzi questa volta un'alzatina e 16
credono entrato nulla eccolo ma cosa ha
preso cosa preso cosa preso quello è
pazzo e passo fatto una parata
incredibile ma cosa sto vedendo occhiali
o celi non puoi pararla la presa
se l'affare è la sfiorata pazzesco entra
niente
due ore di tiri senza un seguono quanto
era sfiorata nella vita ragazzi sa
incredibile in questa partita è
leggendaria erano parate occhio che
quello la ributta va bene
vado io vado io o in mezzo sotto il
palazzo compagini non essere mi sono
detta mio arrivo arrivo rivoli ecco per
te
peccato però perché mattino dio
oddio oddio oddio quando rimbalza ii e
incrementa di fare niente perché anche
se fosse andati in alto magari a venire
ad imbastire un lavoro meritato secondo
me perché entrambi abbiamo giocato in a
c'è stato però adesso lo showdown per
favore dai dai che partita in cuba
pazzesca pazzesca stava ditte pazzesca
vai ricomponiamo ci arriva la partita
non ragazzi fa stesso sto sognando
occhio che volo tira ti prego no vabbè
ai ragazzi è stato io veramente ho perso
avevo 25 anni sono 86 va bene si riparte
così guai due ore di giri a vuoto prima
adesso in tre secondi gol va bene mi
sembra più per i che come le partite iva
che sosterà fino ad avere ore di niente
poi con se ne facciamo dieci ci
rilassiamo va bene bene
mamma mia mamma mi anche sul favor me
lui bravo e brutto gallico meno male che
ci sei ritoccarlo rimasta lì ferma
tristissima a me basta che sia gol si
bravo la tira controllati non tirare
subito sono partito male che è entrata
lo stesso non c'era importa potrai
subito questi terrà gol in 56 mandala
senso dopo le partite le vinciamo così
io niente una teca traversa eccolo bene
a me non è come prima
una donna che tiro traversa però può
arrivare stef il magnifico per latina di
nuovo e la mette in mezzo
che i gol pazzesco raga questo è un gol
pazzesco se posso permettermeli stiamo
quasi controllare questo gol pazzesco
perché glielo messa in rovesciata di
traverso colui che cercava di riparare
poi esatto c'è mamma mia
dopo le partite di prima non ha senso
questa e mi adeguo
bella è bella ma sta lì dove sei
giusto fan pare questa sempre all'inizio
dell'altra e non renato era così adesso
il tempo senza un gol ma lord ci prova
attenzione la tua attentato che è messo
a sparare a tirare la torta fatto bene
ok ma saltato è stato bravo occhio tira
e gol avuta paura del reno razza e
prepara la finanza sta uscendo ho avuto
un po di paura aveva probabilmente tolta
incredibile ok ci sono ma scherzava non
è partito però la palla e comunque di
questi carla vediamo la sbaglia lo stai
con quella prima traversa gol credo
sempre che c'è anche l'italia terra
attraverso il gol non calmare carli
credo bellissimo di mezzo è troppo
troppo e per le lascia tirare dei tiri
pentirai e ove non ho pensato ma anche
lui non ha fatto niente
quelli sì 9 no no no forse la puntata
sul palo non sono vista mente si erano
turbo
ok brasile non l'ho presa che gol
e vabbè ogni tutto questo uso fatto per
te con una mano
quindi non toccata paravo adesso
toccherà lui dopo primo bravissimo
traversa palo tutto ha detto tutto per
lo stesso è preso due traverse cose
eccola la tripletta dello step la
chiedendo troppo liscia non vorrei si
ritiri sette chili sono sempre lì
d'attacco 7 tiri e fatto allora
sincroroller acerba v
mamma mia ok arrivo a rio arrivo si
picchiano speaker orsa maggiore
niente ragazzi sempre ma oggi questa
tirata bene ma ci siamo
c'è la facile medio alta però ha fatto
quella mostra che vinceva sempre
ma se lo meritava tina non sono così
scarsi da prenderne trovi va bene va
bene dagli fastidio
ovvio che tira non attirato perché la
butta lì grandissima perdendo sapete
harmon ma che fa a nola toccata
all'altro sono la risposta
scusami ma ti aspetta bravo bravo 4 loro
madonna poi miei cariati sta partita 9
tiri ben nove chili quattro gol sei
pazzo cioè incredibile verrebbero
qualche festa partite fatte una roba
pazzesca e intel evasori arrendo ma cosa
possiamo dire c'è nel senso
peccato per la prima che per un attimo è
per per tipo se io 7 pali non l'abbiamo
vinta però siamo 5 1 in totale per ora
solo noi due augura che ci siamo ragazzi
ringrazio stefano e per le partite
grazie mille bene anche oggi mi sono
piaciute anche la prima che sto abbiamo
perso è stata molto avvincente fiume
parte più bella raffaella quello che vi
sia piaciuto iscriviti al canale e
lasciato il commentino su cosa ne
pensate soltanto episodi quello stefano
e noi finiamo bei ragazzi
[Musica]